aproximadamente 600 años antes de
cristo- tales de mileto considerado como
el primer filósofo griego fue el primero
en dar una explicación más natural del
fenómeno que observó
una observación clave que hizo fue sobre
unas ciertas piedras llamadas ámbar que
cuando las froto contra un pelaje
mostraron una propiedad muy extraña
parecía que el ámbar había adquirido una
fuerza invisible que podía atraer fibras
pequeñas supuso que el ámbar era
magnético y otra fuerza que observo fue
jugando con una magnetita que son
piedras imán que se forman naturalmente
muchos después de él observaron que el
contacto o fricción contra un pelaje
creaba un desequilibrio algo era jalado
del pelaje y transferido a otros objetos
ahora esto no sólo resultó en una
pequeña fuerza de atracción o repulsión
sino también en un potencial para que
pudieran ocurrir las descargas una vez
que la descarga ocurría la fuerza
desaparecía así que la descarga de
alguna forma revertía el desequilibrio
creado por la fricción
historia también hemos estado fascinados
con los rayos las manifestaciones más
apasionadas de poder y agresividad de la
naturaleza muchas culturas pensaron que
esto era una fuerza divina lejos del
alcance de los humanos y por lo tanto
reservado para los dioses hasta el siglo
17 hay descripciones que afirman la
existencia de algo visible tangible y
ponderable o incluso explican la
existencia de filamentos de luz que se
expanden y contraen y fue benjamín
franklin quien en 1752 pudo comprobar
que hay una conexión entre un rayo y
estas pequeñas descargas que ocurren por
la fricción en un famoso experimento muy
peligroso que hizo sólo con su hijo voló
un papalote en una tormenta y casi hasta
abajo en donde el hilo estaba mojado ató
una llave de hierro y después de un rato
acercó uno de sus nudillos a la llave y
experimentó una serie de pequeñas
descargas
idénticas a las que se creaban por la
fricción con el pelaje esto demostró que
sin duda un rayo es simplemente lo mismo
que esas descargas caseras pero a mayor
escala y en ese momento las personas
empezaron a dividir los materiales en
dos categorías una era la de los objetos
que permiten o aceptan las descargas
como el oro o el cobre que ahora
conocemos como conductores eléctricos y
curiosamente estos materiales también
son muy buenos conduciendo el calor y en
el otro grupo estaban los objetos que no
permiten las descargas como el hule o
los aislantes eléctricos estos
materiales también pueden aislar la
transferencia de calor
y también empezaron a intentar medir
esta fuerza que está les había
encontrado una forma de hacerlo era
suspendiendo un objeto esponjoso de un
hilo y cuando flotaba en el aislante
contra el pelaje y lo acercaban al
péndulo
observaron que lo atrae provocando una
desviación
si agregaremos más objetos observaríamos
que la fricción incrementa debido a una
fuerza de atracción más grande
también observaron que la forma de los
aislantes marcaba una diferencia
aislantes largos y delgados parecían
demostrar una fuerza más grande
y sorprendentemente se descubrió que los
conductores como el alambre de cobre
pueden transmitir ese efecto de
atracción en la distancia esto se
demostró poniendo un alambre largo entre
el péndulo electrostático y el aislante
cargado
cuando pusieron el objeto cerca del
alambre el alambre atrajo y desvió el
péndulo instantáneamente y después
cuando tocaron el alambre con un dedo
ocurrió la descarga y el péndulo regreso
a su lugar inmediatamente la gente
empezó a especular que éste podía ser el
futuro de los telégrafos ópticos en 1774
el inventor francés georges louis lajas
fue uno de los primeros en hacer y
grabar esta idea mandó mensajes a través
de una red de 26 alambres en donde cada
alambre representaba una letra del
alfabeto cuando ocurría una descarga en
una de las terminales el péndulo
electrostático se movía a otra el
problema con este telégrafo era que sólo
podía extenderse entre dos habitaciones
de su casa el poder de la carga era
pequeño y un poco difícil de manejar
pero con el tiempo las personas
empezaron a investigar nuevas técnicas
para generar diferencias de cargas más
grande
y así amplificar la fuerza involucrada
una mejora fue popularizada por
alessandro volta un año después era un
generador de ondas sencillo que podía
crear descargas cada vez que se
quisieran estaba basado en la idea de
que un aislante cargado puede inducir o
transferir la carga a un plato metálico
lo único que había que hacer era poner
el plato cerca del aislante con lo que
se logra la distribución de la carga en
el plato metálico resultando en un
desequilibrio o tensión eléctrica en el
plato de metal entonces al poner un dedo
en el plato la descarga ocurre y luego
se puede levantar el plato usando un
mango aislante y una carga queda
atrapada en el plato el plato puede ser
descargado al simplemente tener contacto
con algún conductor como es un dedo y
sorprendentemente este proceso se puede
repetir muchas veces sin tener que
recargar el plato aislante así es como
podemos generar tantas descargas
pequeñas como queramos y en ese momento
benjamin franklin
estaba enfocado en encontrar una forma
de almacenar o atrapar estas cargas y en
ese momento él pensaba que la
electricidad era una especie de fluido
invisible ya que sabía que podía viajar
a través del agua así que supuso que el
agua adentro de un aislante podía
retener electricidad ahora sabemos que
ese experimento era un frasco de vidrio
lleno de agua con un alambre metálico
que llegaba hasta arriba franklin
también envolvió la parte externa con un
metal conductor
y cuando acerco un conductor cargado a
la parte superior del alambre supuso que
ocurriría una descarga y que quedaría
atrapada en el frasco pero sobre todo
que el frasco podía ser cargado muchas
veces cada chispa amplificaría la carga
hasta lograr una tensión eléctrica
adentro del frasco una buena analogía es
pensar en el frasco como si fuera un
globo cada descarga es como irlo
llenando de agua y después de cientos de
cargas la atención se acumula
y para liberar esa carga simplemente
toco el conductor externo y la parte
superior del alambre
sucedió una gran descarga
franklin mejoró el diseño con el tiempo
y eventualmente descubrió que la carga
no se almacenaba en el agua sino en el
vidrio el agua era solamente un camino
conductor entre el frasco y el alambre
hoy conocemos a eso como un capacitor o
un dispositivo de almacenamiento de
carga y cuando puso muchos frascos
juntos descubrió que podía aumentar la
capacidad aún más hasta incluso liberar
voltajes mortales de electricidad y a
través de los años las personas se
enfocaron en formas más efectivas de
construir cargadores usando máquinas de
fricción que después podían ser
almacenados en capacitores y liberar
manifestaciones espectaculares de luz
hecha por el hombre
durante los siguientes 50 años las
personas trataron de diseñar sistemas
para enviar chispas a través de
distancias más largas
usando alambres más largos y descargas
más poderosas
sin embargo enviar descargas
electrostáticas como un método de
comunicación parecía tosco y arcaico y
no era una mejora con respecto al
telégrafo óptico que existía en ese
tiempo así que eso era muy ignorado por
el gobierno y la industria aunque el
progreso estaba surgiendo la revolución
eléctrica estaba a la vuelta de la
esquina